[Applause]
[Music]
everywhere that I go
it's talk what do you do what I look for
life in the cosmos maybe that last
looking for you are we alone maybe but
not alone
[Music]
well I got those astrobiologist that's
why I sing this song when the aliens
come will they come in peace or will
they make us their pets and put us on a
leash Oh are we alone maybe
[Music]
well I got those astrobiologist blues
and that's why I sing this song
gotta take care of this planet yes sir
cuz it's all we got yes sir talk to me
no we can't move to Venus I can't tell
you without a doubt
[Music]
I don't know but I'll tell you how we're
going to find out tell you how we're
going to find out well we've got to
explore all the potentially habitable
planets in the solar system anyway where
there is or was liquid water energy
organic molecules this includes the cogs
of Venus or subsurface of Mars the
oceans of Jupiter's moon Europa Saturn's
moon Titan and Enceladus and even a
possible interior ocean of Pluto
meanwhile a hundred billion exoplanets
in the Milky Way galaxy for signs of
life in order to do this we'll need to
develop the next generation of space
telescopes and spectrometers so we can
examine those alien atmospheres and
search for the chemistry produced by
life-forms interacting with their
environments these new instruments will
not be inexpensive but they may allow us
to finally answer the age-old haunting
question are we alone so in short kids
if you want to know if there are any l
is write your congressperson and tell
them to increase funding for
astrobiology hey if you like this please
remember everything that we do can be
found commercial-free plus exclusive
original content all on Startalk
all-access comm